within the last hour one of the nurses
credited with saving the life of the
prime minister after he developed
coronavirus has spoken publicly for the
first time Boris Johnson said Jenny
McGee from New Zealand stood by his bed
for 48 hours
our correspondent and Brady has been
following the story today and there he
is at what we've been waiting for this
to hear from one of the people and there
will have been many of them of course
but one of the people responsible for
the PM's care morning Neil yes viewers
will remember when the Prime Minister
was discharged after a week at st.
Thomas's Hospital in central London he
praised all of the NHS staff who had
looked after him but he singled out two
nurses for particular praise he
mentioned Lewis from Portugal and Jenny
from New Zealand and it very quickly
became apparent that Jenny from New
Zealand was Jenny McGee at 35 year old
nurse who has been working in London for
a decade there have been dozens and
dozens of requests for interviews over
the past couple of weeks finally Jenny
McGee has spoken she has spoken to TV
and said and this is what she had to say
my first reaction was that it was a joke
of what my friends are playing a joke on
me I I wasn't expecting it it was
totally out of the blue and it was just
shock just I couldn't believe that what
do you what he'd see it on TV when or
how did you find out I was getting
really really Phoenicia and I was just
doing my usual routine for night shift
and someone takes me just the part that
said Jeannie from New Zealand and I was
like wow I think it's me yeah and in ICU
when did you realize it was Boris
Johnson I had a fear idea that I was
going to be coming in to look after him
and I think it was very obvious and the
median you very quickly that he was in
intensive care at st. Thomas's so I know
I had a fear idea that I was going to be
looking after him all of our intakes of
key chefs are really tough for whatever
reason I think he was there was a lot of
media interests about him being in
hospital and to be honest it's probably
was the toughest thing at a lot as a
unit he was just another patient that we
would try and do that our best for so it
was business as usual a little bit no I
honestly don't think I was it when I got
in the car after work each night and I
could hear things about Boris Johnson on
the news that was very surreal because I
thought wow you know I've just been
looking after him but I really wasn't
fazed by looking after Boris Johnson
so that's Jenny McGee and her week
looking after the prime minister in her
own words so we understand the interview
was filmed in London she remains on
shift at st. Thomas's Hospital and she
finished the interview with a message
for everyone back home in New Zealand to
stay home and to wash their hands and
save lives and she pointed out that you
know New Zealand is is thankfully faring
better than other countries in Europe
right now but her commitment remains to
stay in London and keep working in the
national health service and I thank you